economic sanctions on it's another turn
of the screw from the american side
again targeting vladimir putin and those
closest to him the goal was to maximize
the impact on putin and russia and
minimize the harm on us and our allies
and friends around the world our
interest is in maintaining the strongest
unified economic impact campaign that uh
on putin in all history and i think
we're well on the way to doing that
among those on the list alishir usmanov
one of russia's richest men and dmitry
peskov the kremlin spokesman and one of
putin's closest advisors
19 oligarchs in total sanctioned 47 of
their family members all will be cut out
of the u.s financial system their assets
here frozen and property blocked from
use they also face a travel ban joe
biden hopes putting the squeeze on the
kremlin will make it harder to wage war
but he's aware the conflict is already
driving up prices in the u.s for the
moment there are no plans to put
sanctions on russian oil imports but the
leader of the democrats in the house of
representatives says that could change
i'm all for that ban it
ban the oil ban the oil come from russia
joe biden used the state of the union to
announce a new task force to target
russian oligarchs in the us he's asked
congress for 59 million dollars to fund
it and appointed a top new york
prosecutor to head it it indicates this
could be a long campaign both militarily
and financially
alan fisher al-jazeera at the white
house